HBO has just put out a teaser trailer
for Game of Thrones Season seven called
sigils
the video touches on some important plot
points and conflicts from the stories so
far while hinting that the broader
themes we'll see in the seasons to come
it begins with a three-headed dragon the
sigil of house Tully Rhian the family of
Daenerys we hear Danny talk about her
father the Mad King Aerys who was
notoriously crazy and cruel one of the
central conflicts in Daenerys his
character is the tension between her
trying to be a peaceful and
compassionate ruler while also having a
need for violence and vengeance fire and
blood sometimes worry she's becoming
like her father
we then see a stack sigil of house
Baratheon fighting the Targaryen dragon
this represents Robert's rebellion the
war 20 years ago where Robert Baratheon
defeated Aerys Targaryen and became the
king of Westeros we hear Robert say that
he'll kill every Targaryen he gets his
hands on he hates them partly because
Danny's brother Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
ran off with the woman Robert loved
Lyanna Stark who we saw in season 6
giving birth to Jon Snow
we might find out more about Jon's
parents in this next season we then see
a lion sigil of house lannister savaging
a stag this represents the death of King
Robert which was brought about by Cersei
and Lancel Lannister
also remember that Roberts brothers
Renly and Stannis Baratheon were a thing
for a while until Stannis was killed by
Brienne and Renly killed by a shadow a
vagina monster so it's been a rough
couple of years for the Baratheon family
though Robert's bastard Gendry is still
out there
we see the head of a direwolf sigil of
House Stark and here King Joffrey
ordering the execution of Lord Eddard
things only get worse for the Starks
from there with the deaths of Robb and
Catelyn at the red wedding and the loss
of Winterfell to iron bond into Bolton's
in the books there's a huge complex
conspiracy to return the Starks to power
go watch that video but in
show John and Sansa take back the north
in a battle with the Bolton's bran Stark
meanwhile has become a psychic tree boy
Arya Stark has become a face changing
fray slaying ninja assassin and Rickon
Stark has become a pincushion we see the
tentacles of the Kraken of house
gradually King Balon Greyjoy tried to
make the Iron Islands great again but he
was kind of an idiot and failed ended up
killed by his brother Euron who now
leads the Ironborn towards Dany though
baylin's kids Yara and Theon get there
first
Euron is a seriously scary dude in the
books and there's no doubt he'll be a
major bad guy in season seven of Game of
Thrones
we then see a bear sigil of house
Mormont which is kind of odd because the
moments aren't a major house they're the
family of Liana maged you're and Jorah
Jorah of course has that disease
greyscale and is currently out looking
for a cure funnily enough Sam Tolly has
just arrived at the Citadel the sort of
the University of Westeros if anyone can
heal Jorah that's where they'd be we see
a lion's paw tangled in the thorny
growths of a rose said jewel of health
Tyrell the Tyrells were involved in many
plots to gain power over the Lannisters
but ultimately couldn't scheme their way
out of being blown up by Cersei Elena
still lives though and she joins an
alliance with the sand snakes of dawn
and Varys and Daenerys to fight against
Cersei who crowns herself queen of
Westeros beside her cronies Qyburn and
the zombie mountain there's a nice irony
here in Qyburn proclaiming Cersei
protector of the Seven Kingdoms when
she's done far more damage than good to
the realm Circe's brother and lover
Jaime might finally question his
relationship with her and meanwhile the
other brother Tyrion is on board with
Danny we then get this wide sweeping
view of the whole complex political
[ __ ] that is the last six seasons
of Game of Thrones Daenerys speaks of
spokes on a wheel which alludes to the
ultimate pointlessness of these petty
fights for power the sigils crack and
crumble to dust and we zoom out
show the one war that matters the real
enemy looking like a blue-eyed Sauron on
the screen the others the White Walkers
and their army of the Dead marching from
beyond the wall to destroy everyone no
matter their sigil
there are just two short seasons left in
Game of Thrones and [ __ ] is rapidly
getting real one separate plot lines are
crashing together major characters are
dropping like flies new revelations are
solving old mysteries the seventh season
the show should be spectacular will
speculate in more detail when more
trailers and stuff come out but for now
check out our other videos there are
summaries detailed analyses of theories
and characters and videos on every
episode of Thrones season 6 there will
be a similar series for season 7 also
alt shift X now has some side channels
including old shift Z Zed Z where I read
long boring texts including fairy tales
Bible verses an 18th century erotica and
there's also old schwifty x featuring
Game of Thrones abridged where I give
the loose reading of The Game of Thrones
books there's more of that coming soon
if any of this sounds good to you there
are links to these channels in the
description thank you to the translators
who have been translating the captions
of old chief decks videos so the people
can enjoy them in other languages I
can't thank you all individually or
properly pronounce your names but cat
earth element Phillipe Garcia Veronica
latch your work is very much appreciated
if you'd like to contribute translated
captions there's a link to a guide to do
it in the description now finally thank
you to the patrons who make all GFX
possible including Jason a pygmy Lavinia
Dog David how like crafty miniature
Studios Dominic as Sikorsky Stephanie
nasty Paul Barry Joseph Winfield
Jennifer Reily and sir tomato of Tomatis
Stan Cheers